we just have a statement from Alton
Towers regarding that accident on the
ride called the smiler this is the
statement it says there has been an
incident on the slider this afternoon
involving two carriages coming together
on a low section of the track one of the
carriages was empty and the other had
sixteen guests in the resort's is fully
qualified with first responders who are
on the scene immediately to assist with
the evacuation which is on-going
remember of course his accident happens
at just nine past 2:00 this afternoon is
still under way the area has been closed
to allow for access to emergency
services vehicles to ensure the safe and
timely evacuation of guests a platform
is being constructed this will be taking
a few minutes but will enable us to
proceed more quickly there will be a
full investigation once we have
recovered the guests who are our
priority that statement coming in from
Alton Towers within the last few minutes
of what we do know from West Midlands
Ambulance reiterated there by the Alton
Towers statements 16 people involved
they were on that ride when the
collision took place four have suffered
serious injuries there are four West
Midlands ambulances in attendance air
ambulance and other medics it happened
at nine past two this afternoon so
Richard as we were just talking about
there before we got that statement
there'll be a huge
rescue mission going on to get those
people off that ride